on l'a vu les innovations ne manquent
pas pour des carboner l'avion autre
levier pour accompagner cette révolution
verte des moteurs moins gourmands et
plus efficaces bonjour les gendriers
bonjour David merci d'être avec nous
directeur général du motoriste safran
motoriste et équipements tiersonautique
voilà pour être précis est-ce qu'on est
clair sur le fait que le moteur à
combustion va rester pendant encore
plusieurs années voire plusieurs
décennies la seule technologie capable
de faire voler un avion plusieurs
décennies j'en suis absolument convaincu
et avec le moteur à combustion on fait
de la décarbonation en fait sans le
savoir depuis des dizaines d'années
puisqu'on est sur un schéma où
l'industrie aéronautique mondiale dans
le domaine des moteurs à réduit la
consommation de carburant d'environ 1%
par an chaque année depuis plus de 30
ans donc l'idée c'est d'améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique et donc
effectivement des moteurs notamment
effectivement la décarbonation de
l'aviation ça passe par la sobriété et
la société ça passe notamment par la
technologie et le développement de
moteurs qui sont toujours plus
performants en termes de réduction de
consommation de carburant et donc de
réduction d'émissions de gaz carbonique
puisque c'est
c'est
comment on améliore tout ça il faut des
moteurs plus gros il faut il faut quoi
alors c'est de la technologie
effectivement c'est des nouvelles
générations de moteur et donc pour cela
sans rentrer dans trop de détails
techniques il faut améliorer ce qu'on
appelle l'efficacité propulsive du
moteur et l'efficacité thermique du
moteur et donc comment est-ce qu'on y
arrive sur l'efficacité propulsive ça
passe notamment par une augmentation de
la taille de ce qu'on appelle la
soufflante la soufflante c'est la partie
avant du moteur d'avion c'est le convoi
quand on embarque dans un avion c'est le
moulin en quelque sorte et au plus la
taille de cette soufflante est grande au
plus on brasse de l'air en quelque sorte
on brasse de l'air on crée de la poussée
sans de l'air qui ne passe pas par la
chambre de combustion et ça ça permet
d'améliorer l'efficacité propulsif de
l'avion donc les générations de moteur
suivantes auront des diamètres de
soufflant donc des diamètres de fans en
anglais qui seront de plus en plus
importants ça c'est l'efficacité
propulsive et l'efficacité thermique ça
passe par tout le travail sur les
nouveaux matériaux qui tiennent des
températures plus élevées au centre de
ce qu'on appelle la chambre de
combustion on assiste un renouvellement
de la flotte des compagnies aériennes et
des avions plus performants et des
moteurs plus performants qui sont
équipés de votre moteur notamment le
moteur lip qui équipe la 320 néo et là
le Boeing 737 MAX en quoi est-ce que
encore une fois c'est plus performant
aujourd'hui qu'il y a qu'il y a quelques
années il y a une dizaine d'années on a
décidé de lancer une nouvelle génération
de moteur qui s'appelle le lip le lip
qui motorise à la fois le les dernières
générations de Boeing et d'Airbus donc
le 737 MAX et la 320 néo et qui apporte
15% de d'économie de carburant par
rapport à la génération précédente et
donc tous les avions qui sont introduits
sur le marché aujourd'hui qui sont
actuellement produits et livrés par
Airbus et par Boeing sont des avions
avec ces dernières technologies de
moteur qui apportent 15% de réduction de
mission de caisse carbonique et donc de
consommation de carburant par rapport
aux génération presse et c'est moteur
libre puisqu'ils sont capables
d'accueillir les nouveaux carburants
propres les bocarburants ou ce qu'il
faut attendre la future génération de
moteurs ce qu'on appelle les open rotor
alors les moteurs lip sont certifiés
pour fonctionner jusqu'à 50% avec des
carburants dit durables les carburants
durables aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle les biocarburants donc des
carburants issus de la biomasse ou de
retraitement de d'huile
usagées en fait ça c'est une limite de
certification donc on est actuellement
avec les avionneurs en train de faire
des essais en vol pour voir si on peut
pousser cette limite vers le haut mais
l'Open rotor est-ce que c'est pas ça
l'outil j'ai envie de dire de demain
pour l'avion de demain l'avion hydrogène
l'avion électrique
il y a un saut générationnel vraiment
avec alors nous nous sommes engagés
collectivement le monde de
l'aéronautique s'est engagé
collectivement au mois d'octobre 2021
à atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 et pour y arriver il y a plusieurs
leviers mais les deux leviers essentiels
sont la technologie au niveau de la vie
et au niveau du moteur et puis ce qu'on
appelle les carburants durables sur la
technologie nous sommes convaincus
nous sommes convaincus qu'en travaillant
et en mettant sur le marché un avion et
un moteur disruptif on sera capable de
faire des économies de carburant de
l'ordre de 30 à 35% par rapport aux
toutes dernières génération d'avion qui
sont actuellement produites et sa
disruption elle est pourtant elle est
pourtour 2035 c'est pour 2035 donc un
saut de 30%. dont 20% serait apporté par
le moteur et une dizaine de % par la
violeur et donc sur le motoriste les 20%
qu'on apporterait pour cela on est
obligé d'aller vers des architectures de
moteur disruptive en rupture et donc et
notamment nous nous avons décidé de
travailler ce qu'on appelle un moteur
non Carné le moteur non Carné ça nous
permet d'augmenter le diamètre de la
soufflante encore plus
et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un open
rotor ou un open fan donc ça sera un
moteur qui ressemblera
qui est effectivement qui est qui n'est
pas Carné donc il est quelque part on a
cassé on a cassé les murs pour augmenter
le diamètre de la souffrance et le
rendre encore plus performant et donc on
est où exactement aujourd'hui du projet
parce que 2035 ça paraît effectivement
assez loin alors oui mais dans
l'aéronautique pour arriver à une entrée
en service en 2035 ça veut dire qu'il
faut que les avionneurs lancent leurs
projets d'avion vers les années 2027
2028 et ils le feront en faisant le
choix de notre technologie de moteur si
nous avons pu démontrer d'ici là que non
seulement nous apportons la performance
mais que nous apportons également les
meilleurs garanties de sécurité en vol
et donc il y a tout un programme de
développement technologique et décès au
sol et en vol qui doivent être faits
pour apporter
cette preuve de performance et de
maturité technologique dont les agneurs
ont besoin c'est pour ça qu'on travaille
intensément maintenant donc le
calendrier de 2035 il peut paraître à
nos auditeurs relativement lointains
mais à l'échelle de l'aéronautique c'est
demain après il y a aussi une question
comme c'est un gros moteur il sera
installé oups qui descend à selle sans
carénage il pourra se placer sous les
ailes comme comme pour les moteurs
actuels est-ce qu'il faut revoir le look
l'architecture de des avions alors c'est
évidemment aux avionneurs de travailler
sur la meilleure architecture d'avion
possible mais on peut on peut imaginer a
priori trois options possibles l'option
actuelle qui est des moteurs qui sont
sous elles sous-elle basse et ça ça
suppose quand même d'avoir des jambes
assez longues parce qu'il faudra de la
place sous l'aile pour accommoder le
moteur l'autre solution c'est d'avoir
des des ailes hautes
des ailes hautes et la troisième
solution c'est de les mettre à l'arrière
mais ça ça sera une décision qui sera
prise par l'avionneur qui doit
travailler dans le cas de ces
avant-projets sur l'intérêt de ces
différentes options voilà merci beaucoup
merci pour cette entretien d'en
collision dries directeur général de
safran merci à vous merci David alors on
l'avait beau carburant sont une des
solutions pour décarboner l'avion mais
ils ont risqué à terme de pas en avoir
assez pour satisfaire toute la demande
pour autant un peu carburant nouvelle
génération vous allez voir s'annonce
prometteur
[Musique]